nous sommes en discussion je vous
retrouve sur les liens of fear à nouveau
jeu d'horreur comme avec aussi en masse
était ultra bien notés sur steam c'est
parti on joue un peintre fou à peintre
presque aussi bon que moi voilà sauf que
moi je suis plaint des girafes et pas
lui c'est parti arrêtés black de merde
le cas où chars d'accord merci
ok ça commence on dénonce une pièce
voilà je lui ai dit qu'on joue un
peintre foule à l'air extrêmement
complètement fou on va voir des tableaux
comme ça partout dq d'enfants mais dans
chaque pièce d'art cette maison ça c'est
beau c'est ultra beau hockey c'est parti
on ouvre la porte aux [ __ ] de médias
des rats chez lui ça commence
extrêmement mal
sympa la demeure va prendre son
téléphone pour voir le flash pouvoir
éclairer cauet fera noah affront au
blick ch devra en prendre acte le bon
réflexe
cher monsieur nous aimerions vous
demander d'arrêter de faire de la peine
à nos spécialistes et donc d'arrêter de
nous envoyer vos lettres inapproprié
tous nos employés qui ont visité votre
maison reporter absolument aucun signe
d'infestation de rats ce qui nous a
conduit à ne pas faire une
décontamination de la maison veuillez
prendre cette lettre comme un
avertissement final donc en fait le mec
se plaint qu'il a deja il veut faire
appel à une société et qu ils viennent
en fait y'a pas de rats voilà donc on
est fous on voit des [ __ ] draps c'est
cool
bonjour ouvre-toi [ __ ] mais je me bats
q je vais te buter
je vais avec la soeur de l'apport bordel
de merde alors on a quoi ici aulas la
mildt placard est ce qu'on parte une
petite coquette fromage est ce que ça va
plutôt le coach des casseroles encore
plus long quoi bon gars c'est pas de
baseball quoi les casseroles sont
décodés bon écoutez on a juste porté à l
étage on a fait toutes les pièces de
l'aérien rien du tout oh [ __ ] au nom
jouera de sa voix s'est jeté un coup
d'oeil au jeu mais rougir non pas
longtemps je sens le sang afflue et
partout
ok ok ok vraiment personnel ce que je
joue ici quoi got problème voilà ça
c'est la carte voilà si tu as un
problème de rats tu appelles cette
entreprise ici c'est fermé il ya des
cheveux sa part en grand ce crunch
attention attention moi j'ai fait ça sur
le piano m'a fermé le truc sur les
doigts en la vitesse en vol lourd au
plus tard été une clé direction la salle
en bas avec l'homme le plus malade du
monde
hop là bonjour assertions sur son
atelier ce soit atelier lost et à
bibliothèque au près la peinture partout
et des rouleaux jason jason derulo ouais
je sais c'est blake était très très
longtemps alors abonnez vous j'avoue là
je suis un peu au foulage pas trop quoi
faire bordel bon on va pas bras à
l'époque you quoi pourquoi à tanger
juste le pouce et un tissu
quand je mets les deux le matin y'a pas
de bruit mais qu'un get it right this
time boîte
ok je me casse rien à faire j'ai compris
or voilà ça change a été sur ok on nous
la deuxième peau et bien rien c'est à
vous de vous nous faire flipper a priori
rien
ok eh ben on revient en arrière et voilà
ça recharge et [ __ ] ce labyrinthe
folie actuellement going in circle
donc il tourne en rond d'accord c'est un
problème de tous les artistes un ajout
et bien je suis un artiste et la girafe
j'ai tourné en rond avant de faire la
fête on tournait vous c'est moi
ah ça vient de là il ya un coffre est
une combinaison comment trouver les
chiffres à à 8 5 4 4 8 5
ce pass all back le klose 1 le passé
retient regarder de plus près merci
google donc une bague une chevalière
acheter fréquemment histoire d'or un
embout le dire ça sent le screamer ça
sens à son attention aux [ __ ] s'agit
aura les têtes d'animaux comme
s'accrocha les murs je comprends pas le
phoque boîte vous n'êtes pas un tableau
c'est quoi c'est quoi adam le mec il
tombe résultats dans sa propre maison
travesti ac moga le mec il installe des
pièges pour s'auto piégée à chercher au
haut vous a plu génial non voilà dans la
pièce avec une [ __ ] de poupées là ou
quoi et maintenant le tableau est là oh
là là et là il faut retourner en arrière
et sera changé voilà un tableau mécénat
mais contre moi je suis là haut je
savais mec jolie trp andy plyce des
mensonges qui font très mal
voilà là et évite tous les pièges just
like that choqué le cav est un modèle
bien de cette pause pour un moment je
veux toutes les jolies courbes à des
revers on l'a lu je ne sont pas lus
personnes le centre segal vous un truc
chelou avec cette offre
bonjour [ __ ] draps il va t'en veux
quoi aucun sens ta gueule et tais toi tu
prouves [ __ ] attention voilà voilà
voilà je mettais sur percy tout le monde
savait qui laisse passer un truc
mes mecs vous pas laissés par des livres
quoi c'est ce à quoi la suite quoi papa
qui me fait un croche-patte avait
sérieux je vais à chaque fois qu'on veut
en arrière ça change c'est mon cerveau
explose quoi ok donc la part de la fille
qui est son modèle
plus tôt dans la journée j'ai trouvé
plus de ces petites notes qui parlait de
mes dernières peintures en gros dans les
notes à des knicks ont travaillé dit que
c'est de la merde etc
après tout elle me connaît assez pour
savoir ce qui me blesse j'arrive pas à
croire qu'elle a utilisé sa contre moi
quand je lui en ai parlé elle a dit que
c'est pas elle qui avait écrit et notes
comme si je peux pas reconnaître son
écriture [ __ ] je sais pas quoi faire
ok très bien le mec qui part en steak
quoi le premier pas est le plus dur oh
là là ses premiers pas pour faire quoi
ok [ __ ] sont la cuisine mais quel est
le fuck à what what
waouh attentes mais [ __ ] mais vous
amoureux fous là arrêté à rite
mais mes arrêté au lac en tant qu a pu
traverser la côte [ __ ] ok faut que
j'aille d'avantagé quoi ouais ça brise à
tous a vomi des pommes je veux juste
parfait d'abord j'ai regardé pour du
canevas ce n'est pas juste du canvas
je dois trouver un couteau pas l'un de
ses couteaux bruit il doit être content
comme coûteux coupant comme une lame de
rasoir bonjour je galère j'ai très
doucement flade la peau ok pas il parle
de d'avoir découpé une femme dont je
comprends qu'il faut que je tourne par
cette porte puisqu'elle éclairé et que
c'est totalement une autre pièce de
l'autre côté [ __ ] je peine oui il ya
une peinture qui est apparue en rdc des
dromadaires et là je trouve la porte et
voilà c'est plus la cuisine c'est le
rôle coulant dans le mec mais bon là
c'est quoi c'est un ascenseur au pied on
nous la grille on va là on va où bien
sûr oui à ces rations d'aveyron et pas
en bas non mais t'es sérieux là
non mais c'est carrément hardcore quoi
ça comme technique pour faire peur allez
on sort on se casse
on est deux étages au-dessus la deûle
étage on a vu la personne tu as joué
hier les hommes suis à l'affût quoi aux
clés de mon coeur c'est dur c'est lui
qui a pas sa femme en train de vous du
piano ça c'est le piano choqués on a
voulu jouer tout à l'heure et une notes
sont quoi tu t'arrêtes cette chanson
était parfait kcheche s'il te plaît
juste un peu plus long le temps que je
finisse de paris très bien et le tableau
finalement est en train de fondre et il
ya des cheveux the grudge est passée par
là et des bruits c'est son enfant dans
son chien a hélas pas son chien d'accord
chaque tableau retraçant pris par ses
amis
à 110 au revoir [ __ ] mais moi et mes
tableaux un téléphone qui sonne mais
bonjour je décroche décroche là ou quoi
un faux pas est ce qu'elle est si elle
est à l'hôpital j'arrive allez courage
courage
allez allez le 24 mars ok et séance a
une nouvelle fois j'ai enfin réussi à
jouer un petit peu si taper sur les
touches maladroitement veut dire jouer
du piano je vais pas mentir ça me rend
fou de ne pas avoir le plein contrôle de
mes doigts dans tous les cas j'ai été
rapidement réprimander par mon amour de
marie qui a dit que je devrais rester je
sais qu'il a raison mais comment je
m'améliorais si je ne suis je ne peux
pas travailler
la pire chose et je peux le jurer c'est
que j'ai senti de la liqueur quand il
respirait jeu s'il te plaît pas ça pas
encore au son mari suite à boire
d'accord donc là la femme de ce mec est
un pianiste lui c'est un artiste et je
crois qu'il a des petits problèmes et
fini par boire de la licorne
sa mère le steak mon gars tu es en plus
j'ai la voix péter depuis quatre jours
voilà comment encore plus avoir pété
comme le jeu silent hill qui était sur
ps4 ont cette blague a été péter ok ok
je m'en vais là où la hausse sa mère le
state qu'est ce qu'il va faire dans
cette pièce aurait des notes de l'amour
à la folie un homme appréhendé après
avoir kidnappé sa propre femme what
hockey docteur sepa femme ses filles
auto pour moi donc en gros
apparemment le peintre est allé à dans
un centre pour enfants il a kidnappé
l'une des plus jeunes patientes qui
était en fait sa propre fille la police
a tenté négocier mais ça a foiré donc
sauf une opération bref ils ont récupéré
la fille et ils ont arrêté le suspect le
suspect a dit s'il vous plaît c'est tout
ce qu'il me reste
voilà donc apparemment le suspect c'est
ce peintre 1 dans la logique mais du
coup qu'est-il arrivé à sa femme sa
soupe j'ai trop mal traduit l'histoire
pas du tout cette histoire de bob qui va
au collège qui se fait battre au pierre
feuille ciseaux par carlos à une clé
oh la la c'est quoi ces bruits est si tu
le touches et des lunettes je défends
direct stop stop tout autre à moisir
mecs n'ont occupé occupé il fait quoi
watts et un morceau de peinture qui a
fait ça c'est toi c'est un petit temps
que tu ais je savais qu tavernière
coupable de fuck
cette maison est absolument incroyable
mais ces escaliers avec mes jambes je
pense que tu as le voir me ramener à la
changer quoi que j'en sortirai choix
italien tout comme ça donc cette can
c'est la sienne ou la voleurs de
prothèses je peux pas m'en procurer une
nouvelle en on lui a volé sa prothèse
mecs ont la tristesse quoi elle faisait
pas de volant on va vous retrouver vous
brûler à une unité du genre j'ai besoin
d'une jared un tube en plastique
pourquoi je pense à une seringue watts
qu'est ce qui se passe là temps c'est
quoi le fuck la épaules le sens il a
pris le sens de sa femme pas la peinture
non aulas à aulas est beau on a quoi ici
on sait quoi ça m'agace c'est ce qu'on a
lutté à une fois résumé je crois tout ce
qu'on a trouvé
déjà il je cherchais une toile pas
n'importe quelle toile
il fallait que je trouve un couteau et
pas l'un de ses couteaux pour il fallait
qu'ils soient très coupants autant qu'un
rasoir donc j'ai utilisé un rasoir et
j'ai tout doucement écorché la peau
l'alcool m'a aidé à garder mon calme et
à faire des gestes précis ok donc ça
c'est un morceau de peau nickel et à
côté a tourné au bien de globex et
carrément klaus qui a fait en fait il a
pris une jarre est un tube en plastique
il a mille tubes en plastique dans la
veine de la personne tirée sans dans sa
bouche et ensuite me tue en plastique
dans une jarre pour mettre le champ dans
la jarre bomba et compris super chiant
quand il explique peter personne n'a
envie d'écouter ça j'aurais été le pire
profs du monde et ensuite il dit le goût
du club m'a hanté toute la nuit pour
quoi je n'ai pas pensé une seringue
oui j'avoue du maïs pas obligé de
s'adapter ne bouge pas c'est pas obligé
tuer quelqu'un tout court d'ailleurs
[ __ ] c'est bien beau que ça ben
écoutez je pense qu'on va s'arrêter là
on va faire la suite dans une prochaine
vidéo pas demain je sache si vous a plus
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo
que d'habitude moi je kiffe j'ai envie
de savoir la fin de l'histoire silberg
look hyper prenant aux fauteuils dans
une prochaine vidéo va du coup de main
portez vous bien sûr tout le monde pis
on